(cash register ringing)
- Good to see you, Ghostwriter.
- Follow the money.
What money?
- Who's S?
- Looks like we found
our number one suspect.
-Let's do this.
- Why would Ghostwriter
release characters from the book
unless they were here to help us?
- I am pretty good at solving mysteries.
- Sparkles. They're memories
left behind by other people.
- She's incredible.
- Follow the money.
- You have the best superpower ever.
- Give me a break.
You can talk to ghosts.
- You're telling me.
- There's a monster on the loose.
- Monster?
- (dog whines)
- Frankenstein.
- It was foolish of me to create life.
- Cool.
- We have very different
definitions of "cool."
- We should be formulating
a plan to destroy the monster.
- Let's see if she can help us
with her superpowers.
- Watching memories
is way harder than it looks.
Let me handle the sparkles.
- Curtis and Ruben
are stuck in a sparkle.
- This has never happened before.
- We have to solve this mystery.
It's the only way to get to the truth.
- What have you done?
- We need to leave. Now!
-(roar)
- Aah!
- We come in peace.
- See? I got this.
- I don't got this!